[Music]  history has been made here the first  Kieran's cup finally concluded I just  can't get over what a great tournament  this was and I'm really looking forward  to seeing all of you next year I'm very  happy you've been here and I hope you've  had a good time and hope you can come  back and there was so much fun a real  highlight of the event for me was  getting a tweet from a dad who said that  his four year old daughter had become an  ardent admirer of one of the  grandmasters from watching the show and  I think that's just like a great  evidence that what we're trying to do  with this tournament is working I want  to say a few words faint organisators -  Jeanne - thanks thank you so much didn't  write me I'm so happy to be here I am  already looking forward to next year  I mean sincerely so this event was so  much fun it's like you went to  Disneyland he said can we go back